body count so don't let no older woman
tell you no different keep your body
count Low by shutting your legs
concentrate on your career from now on
because when I heard four
I possibly with you because when I was
like oh 25 I was on four and you're 18
on four it's not good don't do it don't
listen to nobody and I'm telling you the
truth or if I can drive 135 miles to
have sex with my man I will drive 200
miles to [__] block here
[Applause]
that's what I wanted to say because I
couldn't believe that the four I have to
check four and check your age again
that's why I've been waiting there all
quiet because I couldn't believe that 18
year old I had my son at your age and
that's where it stopped do I mean one
and my son at your age and you're having
four you're gonna have children stop
before you get pregnant it stops you
don't have nothing